thank you robert
uh good morning everybody welcome to
this joint audit and standards committee
i am councillor dave muller and i am
chairing the meeting today
may i first remind you all of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distance from all other persons in the
chamber and in social areas
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless
when you are moving around the building
once you have taken your seat you may
remove your mask please ensure that you
use the hand sanitizer and the wipes
provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting and during any
breaks
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure that your mobile phones
are on silent or switched off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those same recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
i'd like to know make some introductions
the officers attending the meeting today
are rebecca hewitt the acting corporate
manager for financial operations good
morning rebecca
john snell the corporate manager
internal audit and data protection good
morning john
and i'd like to welcome mark hodgson who
from ernst young auditors who's joining
us for the first time today to welcome
mark to the committee we have mandy
smith and robert carmichael as our
governance officers today
i'd like to know move to the agenda
um can i have the apologies for absence
and substitutions please randy
thank you chair we've received apologies
from councillor barrett and councillor
lindsay
and councillor rosen and war boys are
absent from the meeting at present thank
you very much
right item number two declarations of
interest do any members have any
declarations of interest
none okay i'd now like to move to paper
jac stroke 21 stroke 9 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 27th
of september 2021
and we're looking for accuracy only
happy with the meeting the minutes can i
have a proposal and a second to please
okay councillor haran and councillor
casten as the seconder i'd now like to
ask the governance officer please if we
could go to the electronic vote thank
you
thank you chair members the
vote is now in progress on the app
that's that's unanimous chair six votes
for
number four to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
no petitions thank you very much and do
we have questions by the public no no
questions and questions by councillors
thank you very much i now move on to
agenda item number seven this is jac
stroke 21 stroke 10 the half year report
on treasury management for 21 22 and i
would now like to invite rebecca hewitt
the acting corporate manager for finance
operations to present the report over to
you rebecca thank you
thank you chair good morning councillors
and so this is report jac
21-10 is the half-year report on
treasury management for 2021-22
so this is the joint treasury management
report covering the position for the
first six months of the financial year
2021-22
it provides details of performance
effects of decision taken during that
period and compliance with the council's
treasury management policy
the report explains the factors
affecting the strategy and activities
including the regulatory framework
economic conditions interest rate and
liquidity risk
interest rates during the year have
continued at very low levels and the
bank of england base rate has remained
at 0.1
the economic recovery from the
coronavirus pandemic continued to
dominate the first half of the financial
year
the easing of restrictions boosted
activity in the second quarter of the
calendar year helping push gdp up by 5.5
quarter on quarter
the employment rate increased and
economic activity rates decreased
suggesting an improving labour market
picture
annual cpi inflation rose to 3.2 percent
in august and the bank of england now
expects inflation to exceed 4 by the end
of the calendar year owing largely to
developments in energy and goods prices
more specifically for the two councils
as highlighted in appendix c paragraph
5.4 there was one occasion where babur
exceeded its daily bank limit with
lloyds by 136 000.
this was due to lloyd's online banking
system being unavailable for the day
meaning that no balances could be
invested
for mid-suffolk banking activities
undertaken were within the daily bank
account limits
each council has reduced its debt paper
by 5.4 million and mid-suffolk by 9
million
all investment activities undertaken
were in accordance with the approved
counterparty list
the council's investment activities
included average returns can be found at
appendix c of the report
investment by both councils in funding
circle has reduced as unallocated funds
have been reclaimed and existing loans
repaid
for both councils investment reduced by
31 000 leaving the balance at 30th of
september as 135 000 for baber and 131
000 for mid suffolk
both councils are compliant with the
upper limits for interest rate exposure
the investment activity undertaken for
the first half year was done so in
priority order of security and liquidity
over yield as prescribed in the treasury
management strategy
i would now welcome any questions that
you may have on this report
thank you rebecca
now open the floor to questions please
for rebecca do we have any questions for
members thank you
thank you very much mr chairman um i
might be um
taking something away from council
mclaren who's actually a baby counsellor
if you're gonna ask about the um
overdraft limit then exceeded
i'll give way to council mclaren because
she's a baby counsellor
thank you councillor caster chair thank
you
rebecca obviously that sort of um was
identified in the recommendations
i just need a very practical sort of
explanation for that
um
i'm very simple-minded so i looked at
that
what
does each council have a different bank
so mid-suffolk and baber
bank with a different bank that's one
question
and
um
following on for that
if they do share the same bank why did
they not have the same impact if it was
a system failure
i was wondering why it hadn't impacted
mid-southwest
thank you thank you
thank you for your question councillor
um they do both bank with the same bank
so they are both with lloyds and the
reason that babe would have been
affected in mid-south not affected would
simply be due to the need to invest on
that day
um so i think baber had a balance which
would have been over the the two million
limit that we had in the account whereas
just due to cash flow mid suffolk
weren't in that position so we didn't
need to invest on that that particular
day
okay
sorry i thought i didn't know whether
councillor custom was going to come back
thank you
were there any charges or what were the
implications of going over for that
period
thank you for the question um so there
was no charges for us for going over so
it is a limit that we have for our own
and purposes so to anything over 2
million we try and invest
for interest rate to get interest on the
on the money
um so the implications would be that we
would have lost
a day's interest
on that
which i think i've estimated to be
probably around about three pounds for
that that one night
no so one
just to clarify so that wasn't actually
set by the bank that was set by us so
the there really was very little um
problem we're going over but it's
obviously got to be noted in this report
that's correct so it's like reset
rebecca do we have any more questions
please for um the corporate manager mary
thank you chair
rebecca looking at the investments
i tried to get my head around each one
of each part of it
i sort of get the impression and you can
contradict me if i'm wrong that we're
rather cautious
with our investment programme
and so that's the question that's the
first question do we err on the site i
can understand the reason for that but
do we err on the side of caution
and the second question is if we do
who actually
makes that decision
is it
the
section one five one officer
is it
a cabinet decision or do all in close
sort of advisors
to be cautious thank you chair thank you
thank you
so we do have set limits on the
um instruments that we can invest in
that will be set as part of the treasury
management strategy
at the start of the year and so that
will be in consultation with arling
close obviously because it's council
taxpayers money and we have to consider
security over everything else so
um part of that consideration will be
those that are secure and we'll set
limits in in consultation with island
clothes that we will
work to during the year
okay
so
like
cabinet
the portfolio holder for finance in both
councils do they have any
influence on that decision about
investments
um only in the the process of setting
those
um
approving those uh treasury management
strategy
at the start of the year which would
come through here and then go to council
um certainly as part of that process
no decision making there really no so
the day-to-day decisions would be made
by the section 151 officer based on the
limits in the treasury strategy
thank you rebecca thank you
very much occasional mclaren do we have
any more questions please uh
coach lehren please thank you
yes thank you chair i'm quickly rebecca
i feel i should know the answer to this
but on the hra long-term borrowing
it's 89
million i presume this is the how this
is the money we had to borrow to buy
back the council houses we thought we
already owned doesn't it it's that one
isn't it
and when this was taken out there it's
like a mortgage i didn't expect it to go
down on a yearly basis but it seems to
have been stuck at this figure for um
quite a while
and i just wondered why that was i
remember it's very controversial and i
was against it i expected at least it'll
get a bit less each year but it doesn't
appear to be doing so um i wonder if you
just remind us of the arrangements and
why it's not getting any less apparently
please
certainly thank you for the question um
it was a range of loans that were taken
and you're correct it was to buy out of
the subsidy system and there's a
different
they took a range of different loans at
different maturities
um so there it's not annuity it doesn't
pay off continuously i think there's
different range of loans so some of
those will start being paid off
in the next next few years i can check
on for more details if
if that would help
come on out of meeting about that it's a
difficult one yeah thank you chairman
thank you very much um i've got one
question rebecca i know with funding
circle we're down to one percent is that
likely to stay at one percent or are we
thinking of eventually going away from
funding circle all together please
thank you i understand that the
intention is to move away from it all
together but i will clarify that
uh councillor casten please
thank you yeah and in regards to your
funding circle
um
what
kind of funding circle product have we
got because i couldn't really um
see there is a um
is it a fund of many different
loans or is it has the arlington close
chosen who to invest with or um yeah
could you just clear up how that works
yes thank you um it is a fund of
different loans um i don't know exactly
how that works i would have to go away
and find that out but yes it's a
it's a fund of different loans
okay then i will now open up the issue
for debate do members would like to
debate this issue
counselor casting
yeah i think as always it's a um it's a
good report i'm really glad to see that
exceeded overdraft isn't very serious
because i was i did think that was the
major thing on this but it to me it
doesn't seem like too much of an issue
um
quite exciting about the uk
infrastructure bank and the
possibilities with that and
the changes to the um
pwlb but um yeah for me this is good and
um
yeah i'd like to um
do we are we recommend
we're noting this aren't we so what
we're going to do there are three votes
on this particular paper so i would do
those individually
the first one is actually
as as it states on page 11 that the
treasury management activity for the
first six months of 2021 22 has set out
in this report and apparently has been
noted i know we normally just don't vote
on a note if it is actually down for
voting on the electronic vote so um are
you if no one else wishes debate are you
proposing that we
um go for the are you proposing to go
for that recommendation yeah yeah if we
yeah i'm proposing to move forward if
everyone's happy can i have a second to
please counselor mclaren thank you can i
ask the government's officer please if
we could go to electronic vote for 3.1
please
thank you chair um vote 3.1 is uh in
progress
um i did have it confirmed that we need
votes for this because the committee is
confirming that the treasury management
complies with the number of statutory
requirements so that's why we need to
have the votes thank you
that's unanimous chairs six votes four
thank you very much um mandy
now
recommendation 3.2 is for baber
councillors only to vote on can i have a
proposal in the secondary for
recommendations mary uh council mclaren
and councillor haran and i'll read the
recommendation to you that it be noted
that baba district council's treasury
management activity for the first six
months of 2122 was in accordance with
the approved treasury management
strategy and that except for one
occasion when the council exceeded its
daily bank account limit with lloyds by
136 000 pounds as mentioned in appendix
c paragraph 5.4 the council is complied
with all the treasury management
indicators for this period so can i ask
the governance officer please to go to
the electronic vote and say this is for
baba councillors only thank you thank
you chair that vote is now in progress
thank
[Applause]
that's unanimous three votes for
thank you very much uh mandy um and the
recommendation to mid suffolk council
which is item 3.3 in the list of
recommendations and can i have a
proposal and a second for that please
counselor norris and councillor caston
and i'll just read the recommendation to
you
that it be noted that mid suffolk
district council's treasury management
activity for the first six months of
2122 was in accordance with the approved
treasury management strategy and that
the council has complied with all the
treasury management indicators for this
period so i will now ask the actual uh
governance officer to open up the vote
please
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
that's unanimous six votes uh three
votes for sorry
thank you very much indeed mandy
i'd now like to move on to item number
eight which is the gac stroke 21 stroke
11 the joint audit plan for 2021
and i now like to invite mark hodgson
from ernst and young external auditors
to present his report over to you mark
thank you
thank you and morning everybody so yeah
mark washington uh partnering henson
young
and taking over from suresh patel as
your
signing partner on both audits
so just as background i also do suffolk
county council um the pension fund and
west suffolk council within my portfolio
and lead our team across east anglia
so the plan before you is our plan in
order to gain sufficient audit assurance
um to sign our audit opinion in respect
of the 2021 financial statements for
both councils
and i'll pick out a couple of highlights
and then take any questions members may
have
so on our page five we set out um the
key risks
to the audit
and why they are there
so in a in a year with a lot of change
there are some new risks in there
and the ones in relation to grant
funding bad debt provision collection
fund accounting and non-domestic
rate appeals are all as a consequence of
covid19
and the financial reporting consequences
that that has on a set of financial
statements so they are new risks for
this year in order to get assurance over
those
we also increase the risk in relation to
the
community infrastructure levy
because there were a number of audit
errors last year so clearly we need to
make sure they are
correct this year and we have assurance
over those
all the other risks in that table and in
the plan in section two are consistent
with the prior year so hopefully you get
a sense that things are the same
plus covered plus last year's error that
we need to get assurance over
um then moving on to materiality which
is pages eight and nine of our report so
for baby council we're working to a
materiality level of 1.154 million
pounds
so in summary any audit differences
above that that were not adjusted would
cause us an issue for our audit opinion
and in relation to mid-suffolk on the
subsequent page it's
1.205 million
and then when we come back with our
results of our audit in
february time we'll be reporting any
audit differences above 58 000 and 60
000 respectively to you so you can see
what has moved through the audit against
those risks and that materiality level
section three of the plan sets out
our responsibilities for value for money
and these have changed slightly this
year
so the national audit office has issued
a new code to all auditors
and the changes in the code are kind of
three-fold
so firstly auditors have to report any
significant risks that we identify
and then what procedures we would be
carrying out against those risks we are
yet to conclude that work but i will
bring it back to you at a subsequent
meeting
once we've completed our work we would
report any matters
against significant risks in our audit
report so our audit opinion so in effect
this is the same as it would be as
qualifying an old value for money
conclusion the kind of the terminology
of the wordings now move to we would
report by other matters and then at the
end of the whole process
we issue a commentary which shows you
how we got to the conclusion we reported
in the opinion so it's a little bit
circular it goes backwards and forwards
but hopefully it gives you as members
and the public a little
or greater sense of how we've identified
risks addressed those risks and then
been able to conclude the audit
and then the last section in terms of
audit fees
we have set out the same approach as we
did last year we're still waiting for
public sector audit appointments to
determine formally the fee in respect of
2019-20 so our figures are exactly the
same as last year until we get that
determination
those are the highlights that i wanted
to get across but i'm happy to park it
there and take any questions anybody
would have
thank you mark do you members have any
questions for mark please
um
when you said about reporting
significant risks who's that reporting
to you is that reporting to us or
another body sorry i didn't quite
understand it
it will be reporting back to you so
it'll be an update to this audit plan
with any value for money risks that we
identify
no
then i'd like to move into debates would
members like to debate this paper
councillor casten thank you
thank you mr chairman
um
yeah it's um it seems like another
layer of protection on there the um
i was a little bit confused with the um
with the risk management being a um
instead of the actual risk being the new
inherent risk um being um bright red but
i soon got to grips with it and i think
it's a much better way of looking at it
because um
having been on this committee
um a little while it it helps you um
focus on
um
the the new issues which you know that's
the most important part of this so um
yeah
it looks it looks good to me and um
i'm
very happy with it
yes i just want to say and commend um
the auditors on their report because i
it was very succinct
and
easy to understand so thank you
other members wish to take part in
debate
no and i also would like to thank um
ernst young for the their report so
thank you very much indeed mark for that
okay we have a recommendation and the
recommendation is
that the proposed
provisional approach for the 2021 audit
to be agreed can i have a proposal and a
second to please councillor norris to
propose and a second to please
councillor none thank you very much
so pleased to go to the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that's uh six votes for
unanimous
right i now like to move on to agenda
item number nine this is jac 2112 the
interim internal report for 2122 and i
know like to invite jon snell the
corporate manager for internal audit to
present the report over to you jonathan
thank you chair and good morning
councillors
um as required under the public sector
all its standards uh internal the
purpose of this report is really to
conform
members uh of the work undertaken within
the internal audit service for the first
six months for 2021-22
and it also provides counselors with a
review of the variety and scope of the
projects and corporate activities
which are supported through the work of
the team during the year
you will see from the work undertaken
that uh of the completed audits
only one returned an ordered opinion of
the control environment of limited
assurance
and that was based at the end of last
financial year 2021
so in line with our internal order
procedures this order was followed up
and i'm pleased to report that
improvements have been made in this
particular area since the the initial
audit and the audit opinion
has elevated from limited assurance to
reasonable assurance
the full status of this particular
follow-up report which is a tribute to
housing and the health and safety issues
is reported in section six of this
report
below and also um together with all the
audits that are undertaken during those
six months it gives you a status
position
as well as conducting audit reviews
internal would have a significant
involvement
within the period
in a variety of different council
activities
and this includes leading on the
production of the annual governance
statement
2021 which was presented to this
committee back in may
also attending the council's statutory
offices working group
and that's my role is there is to
provide
appropriate and professional
determination on governance issues again
through the period as they arise
i'm also one of the council's two deputy
monitoring officers
and so my role primarily is really to
support emily your the council's
monitoring officer
with a specific duty to ensure that the
the councils their officers and elected
councillors
maintain the highest standards of the
conduct in terms of the work that they
do
internal audit continues to maintain and
facilitate the the deployment of the
council's significant risk register
and again that's reported back to this
committee and also has that consultation
with slt
as we move forward
in terms of full details of the
anti-fraud and corruption work which i'm
also responsible for
my role is to report to you on an annual
basis
uh in terms of what our findings were
and this was last presented to to this
committee back in march
uh until recently internal audit have
been part of the council's tactical
management team
responsible for managing emerging risks
and directing resources to help
ensure critical services are maintained
across the two councils particularly
obviously with the kovit 19 pandemic
in particular
my role is now just called upon when
it's required particularly with the
governance arrangements and these
associated risks that
we need to address right across those
two councils
i also have a member of the internal
audit team who continues to support the
council's business cell by providing
assurance over the administrating of the
various business grants schemes which
obviously have been announced through
central government throughout this
pandemic
there's no additional audit related
issues that i think i need to bring to
your attention at the moment so i'm
happy at this stage to field any
questions that counsels may have on the
report thank you
thank you john do we have any questions
please for a job for members
thank you mr chairman
uh on
page 107
planning enforcement
it says work in progress but there's no
schedule there
timetable for when it's anticipated to
be completed could you give some
indication on that because this is a
sort of a very hot subject actually at
the moment thank you yeah thank you
councillor for your question um the
reason i put a work in progress is
actually the report the draft report is
imminent so at the moment the auditor
who undertook the work is having
conversations with phil isabel and his
team
the reason why i haven't
put a summary of the findings at the
moment they still need to be discussed
obviously with management and they need
a management decision but this will be
reported back at the year end when i do
my annual audit reports
so hence why it's working progress at
this stage but it's just to alert you as
members that we aren't undertaking this
work and it will be reported in full at
the end of the year uh probably march
april time next year
thank you chair
john
excellent paper but um
i quite like questioning sort of
nebulous subjects
and
you've mentioned on page 100
about ethics being audited
um
could you explain to us how
you go about that
okay
yeah thank you it's um
sometimes a bit of a dry subject um but
with my
my head of audit hat on but also my
deputy monitoring hat on um as i
probably mentioned
excuse me
um ethical is critical the values that
we actually attain both as officers and
members um the ethics standards if you
like in terms of the work that we do
is more focused on the offices within
the audits that we undertake so we're
looking at part of an holistic approach
to our audit work we're looking at
behaviors and conduct of officers and
how their services are manifested to our
customers as well so there's always an
element that we're very conscious
so that's why we try and draw in with
the ethics side of the audit but it's a
holistic approach on that side so we
would expect um our officers to be
operating to a high standard and the
values that set those five stanzas that
are set and been signed off by members
so that's how we try to integrate it
within our work that we do so where we
see
examples poor examples of behaviour
in terms of their conduct or
generalization in terms of those five
values we would report report that on
and report it back to management
so if i was a new member of staff
would
that be defined in
some training or
other set policies that you can refer
staff to
yes certainly part of
the the induction phase undertaken by
our hr and also the manager they report
to the line manager there's the code of
conduct for employees and they are
required to read and sign that they have
actually read and understood the
contents of that document
thank you very much mr chairman on this
some housing health and safety
um
with the
the
it says the policies and procedures
um may have been to blame
with the um the
bad outcome the limited assurance um how
far are we along with that looking at
those policies and dealing with that
sorry thank you councillor yes so um
just to draw back in terms of when it
received a limited assurance there was a
lack of
clarity if you like in terms of policy
and procedures they weren't signed off
they weren't necessarily embedded and as
a result we found a number of issues in
terms of supporting documentation and
reconciling the compliance checks that
were required
since then that we've um the housing
section
devising at what's called a dashboard so
they're bringing all the information
together and capturing it in one place
part of that dashboard is obviously to
have a look at the policies and
procedures and my understanding from
when i spoke last to gavin they are in
draft format they just need to be
formally signed off and then
disseminated through right through the
whole of their team so they're well
underway to do that and i think
the
part of the problem was they've gone
through a restructure
and it was fairly fluid and i think to
be brutally honest there was a slight
lack of management oversight as a result
of that now that's been drawn in and
there's a dedicated officer dealing with
that he's overseeing it and as a result
the that audit opinion as i said is
elevated to reasonable assurance there's
still a little way to go
but the key controls are now in place
if that provides a level of assurance to
your counselor
please please
counselor haring please
yes thank you chairman um morning john
the thing that sort of left off the page
to me is the asset management um
it sounds if something is going on but
we're not quite sure what and it sounds
also as if
we've lost control of sort of lists of
what we actually own
um
is that a fair comment and
basically um where are we with that
because i would find that worrying
really
yeah thank you
thank you councillor so um
on page 111 um you'll see that um part
of that audit um was to do as say with
asset management and actually providing
that assurance over the effectiveness
and control of our assets et cetera as
you'll see that's work in progress as
well so it's just a timing issue at the
moment so that's almost imminent so
again we'll be reporting back at year
end
but we're having conversations at the
moment we're up practically at draft
stage reports so we're just waiting for
some management response before we can
formally issue it that but that will
come through to this committee as i said
at year-end report
so john that will come before us when
did you say uh next year's um probably
about april april may time in terms of
the forward plan uh that's when i will
produce my annual report for the whole
of the year and you'll see
where we've got work in progress they
would have been completed so you'll have
a full picture in terms of the audit
coverage and the findings of those
individual audits
okay thank you john because i would um
deem that sort of um quite important
yes okay
excuse me not so much a question as more
just a a comment to john on his work and
progress items would it be possible just
to give an indication when you're likely
to be able to give a conclusion to this
work because it saved us then answering
asking the questions wouldn't it
yes certainly i think that's a very
valid point and as i said if i'll put
what i'll do is i'll consider that
obviously for the year-end report so if
there's any work in progress there
hasn't been concluded i will put a time
frame
for you so at least you can have that
indication
to pick it up when we report next to you
but there's a very valid point so thank
you councillor
you
know
i'd like to concur with what council
norris says on that
john i think that's really really
important that we do have a timeline as
to when these reports are expected thank
you
in that case i'd like to
thank you
do we need to um condition to have those
timelines on the end of the year end or
i i'm quite happy to um
for um
john chanel to say that he's
he's going to give them to us at the
year end but i just
wondered if members thought we should
condition it in future reports
yeah um
personally i don't think there's a need
for that
certainly from my experience in the past
working for district audit the audit
commission um we used to sort of give a
timeline as when the re results were due
so
and john's taking that on board so if
members are happy that then i'm more
than happy because john's agreed to do
that so it's up it's up to the members
if they wish to go for that thank you
yeah and i'll follow your lead on it i
don't think it's an issue maybe i'm used
to being in planning meetings where
everything needs to be conditioned and
put in or it might disappear
counselor do we have any more um we're
in debate does anyone else wish to
debate this this topic
thank you very much thank you very much
indeed for your report john that is much
appreciated
the recommendation is that the contents
of the internal audit report supported
by appendix a be noted therefore
i would no like to move on to item 10
and i would now like to invite john
again the deputy monitoring officer to
present the report the complaints
monitoring report thank you john
thank you again chair
uh so what do you have in front of you
so in line with each council's um
constitution the monitoring officer is
required to provide this committee with
an update
on code of conduct complaints received
or determined since
last time that such complaints were
reported to to this committee
so the report covers complaints received
in the four months period from july to
november and also shows the previous
four-month period
the table shows that for baber there's
been a reduction in the total number of
complaints received and those that have
been received related more to parish
council complaints
rather than a district council level
so of the six complaints received only
one of those was upheld
which related to an issue around a lack
of respect
for mid-suffolk there's been a
noticeable increase in complaints
received
with all but one
complaint at parish council level
seven of those complaints which equates
to about 50 percent
were upheld and related to the same
incident covering uh issues of bringing
the council in to disrepute
the mo and
emily's dmos myself and jan robinson
also continue to receive high number of
general governments inquiries
from pre-complaint advice from town and
parish councils
i'm happy to take any questions
but just a bit of a caveat i won't be
able to
divulge or go into any details on
specific complaints because of the
nature the sensitivity and the
confidentiality aspect
but happy to talk generally about
complaints
thank you chair thank you john do we
have any questions please for john
councillor mclaren please thank you john
um
the independent person
in in the complaints management
could you just expand on that
who is it or where do they come from are
they from outside the organization thank
you yeah thank you councillor so the
independent person is a part of the
requirement as it is it's an independent
so they're totally objective and it
helps to support and add
integrity to the whole process
so we
employ four
uh independent persons and they are
agreed across suffolk
and they are individuals are interviewed
for their suitability
and experience it doesn't necessarily
don't have to necessarily come from a
public sector
but they should show attributes in terms
of fairness and also those principles
lord know
nolan's principles are the seven
principles of fairness um so um that is
part of our process so once we receive a
code of conduct where we think there's a
potential breach we will do an uh an
initial assessment that we then pass
that on to the independent person to
agree what our assessment is
or not
before we take it to the next stage
so
is is that
post
remunerated
it it can be it's not quite as
straightforward as that so if you tend
to get a lot of complaints and
particularly more of a complex nature
we can
pay that individual
but normally no
and where does that show in the accounts
that would go through presumably
our monitoring officer has a budget um
so that would go through there and
that money were taken out from the
budget which is already preset
thank you
with these some complaints on parish
councils and councillors and district
councillors um do the um
do the councillors know that there's a
complaint and um do we have any way of
reacting to those complaints like
training or anything like that or are
they just purely for
noting
it's a good question counsellor um in
terms of whether they know yes if there
has been a breach they would be advised
of that breach and they have the
opportunity to respond to the complaint
uh if no breach has occurred
um generally we don't notify them
um because there's no breach to answer
um in terms of training the sanctions
that
we can impose at the moment um to be
perfectly honest the code of conduct the
suffolk local code of conduct
doesn't have a great deal of teeth if
i'm brutally honest
but we try to resolve things amicably
between the parties
um particularly where training is
required so if there where a breach has
occurred through
any of the breaches that potentially can
take place against that code we would
then
make recommendations that they undertake
further training so it's not repeated
but coming back to the point in terms of
the sanctions there's not a huge amount
that we can impose
uh on
councillors generally per se whether
it's the district council or parish
councillors
but the code is being revised
as we speak and there may be more
sanctions that we can apply but that
needs to be ratified first
and again that will be brought back to
this committee
mclaren please
i'll just follow up on council casting's
question
in the in these instances uh the ward
members are not advised if
or are they of trouble with the parish
council
if if we feel there's significant issues
within their ward yes they would be as a
matter of courtesy so what we wouldn't
want to do is
for any councillors here for example
not to be aware of any serious matters
that they might get ambushed if they
were to attend the parish council
meeting
that's not in the interests of us as the
monitoring officers or for you as
district councillors
to get caught up in that if you weren't
given
sight of what's coming around the corner
and do salt get involved with this
process
yes uh sorry cancer yes uh in in
particular with um some of the training
so we work closely with salk
um they have a clear role and we have a
clear role and sometimes there's a
little bit of gray area
but we would sometimes take advice from
sulk in moving things forward
there some for example would get heavily
involved with say issues around the
parish clerks we don't have any
jurisdictions against them because
they're employed by the parish council
so matters of that would be referred to
say the chair and also they could seek
advice from salt but generally
code of conduct issues are dealt with by
us as the monitoring officers at
district council level
thank you john
do we have any more questions for
members please
no
in that case thank you i will now open
the item up for debate members the floor
is yours for debates
no
okay
thank you very much therefore the
recommendation is
that the code of contact complaints
monitoring information contained in
paper jac 20 stroke 16 be noted
and thank you so we're now moving on to
agenda item 11 and this is jsa
2114 the forward plan are there any
suggestions comments or amendments
please to that plan
okay
yeah
i have no amendments or anything i'm
pretty happy with it thank you very much
are any do any other members have any
comments or
amendments etc
no okay thank you very much indeed uh
that actually concludes the meeting and
the next meeting is currently scheduled
for the 24th of january 22 commencing at
9 30 a.m so i'd like to thank everyone
for attending today and thank the
officers for the various papers that
they've presented and obviously as we're
not meeting until after christmas i hope
you all have a nice christmas and a
happy new year
probably the first one to say that this
year
you